in the last video we talked about how
the Fourier series can be used to
estimate a lot of weird functions on an
interval by just using functions of this
form we call these the complex
Exponential's remember if we wanted to
estimate some function we multiplied
each of the exponential functions by a
number called its weight and then we
added the Exponential's together the
Fourier series tells us which weights to
use we found that for a lot of functions
this worked really well the next natural
question is whether we can use the same
trick to estimate a function on the
whole real line it's tempting to say
that if a certain combination estimates
the function well on the interval surely
the same combination must estimate the
function well on the whole real line
that's not the case at all though as you
can see from these examples that's where
the Fourier transform comes in it comes
up with a way to estimate the functions
on the whole real line using complex
Exponential's before we talk about how
though let's think about these complex
functions e to the power ikx the real
part of this is a COS function and the
imaginary part is a sine function and
both bits have the same wavelength how
does that wavelength relate to K well
the wavelength is in fact 2pi divided by
K we call K the wave number if we think
back to the Fourier series we only
needed to use Exponential's with certain
values of K unfortunately that's not the
case if we want our estimates work on
the whole real line we need to consider
the Exponential's with all possible K
values now say that we have a function f
that we want to approximate on the real
line we need to figure out exactly how
much of each of these Exponential's we
need to add together to get a good
approximation so in other words we're
looking for some function of K basically
something that takes a value of K and
tells you how much of the corresponding
exponential you need to add this is
pretty much what the Fourier transform
is let F hat be the Fourier transform of
a function to understand it we're going
to have to look at the equation that
relates f hat to its function
okay so don't freak out I know there's
an integral there and so it seems
difficult but it's really not if you see
my calculus video or you know something
about tack ulis already then you know
that the integral itself is just about
an approximation so we'll come at it
from that kind of angle first we pick a
small number let's start with half what
we're going to do is get the best
approximation we can to our function
only using complex Exponential's with K
values that are multiples of half our
task is to find the weights to put in
front of each of these functions okay
suppose we know the Fourier transform of
our function already we're going to
restrict our attention to the points on
the graph where K is a multiple of a
half it's tempting to think that the
weights to put in front of each of the
Exponential's should just be given by
the value of the Fourier transform at
that K but that's not quite right
actually the appropriate weight is the
area of each of these sections in other
words the Fourier transform multiplied
by half let's see how good this
approximation is to our actual function
hmm not too bad actually it's the right
kind of shape at least but we can do
better let's try using Delta X equals
1/4 now we've got more Exponential's to
work with we'll use a similar process to
find the weights we'll look at the
relevant parts of the Fourier transform
again the weights are given by these
areas which in this case is the height
multiplied by 1/4 now let's see how good
this is it's a bit better than last time
so we can go ahead and do the same
process with Delta X equals 1/10 we can
repeat the process with smaller and
smaller Delta X's and by the time that
Delta X equals one hundredth we can
hardly see the difference between the
two functions if we wanted to summarize
what we just did in equation form we'd
write it like this
furthermore the smaller we make Delta X
the better the approximation so we'd say
that F equals the limit as Delta X goes
to 0 of all that stuff on the right-hand
side this by def
Nishan is the integral of f hat times e
to the ikx DX this if you remember is
the integral we were trying to explain
so you can see that the Fourier
transform function tells us which of the
exponential functions to give the most
and less weight to when we approximate a
function using the Exponential's so
that's how a Fourier transform relates
to its function the surprising fact is
that there are some interesting links
between the two next episode we'll
explore this relationship in particular
I'll explain why the Fourier transform
makes the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle happen so I'll see you for
that if you're interested